josh jr have you thought about doing
stand-up or have you done stan before
and josh senior
have you embarrassed yourself in front
of your son that he can joke about
i think i could do my own version of one
of your jokes
because i have the exact same not the
exact same but
i have a similar experience to one of
your jokes i'm not going to tell you
which one it is on here because i don't
think i've ever told you this
but i think you can probably you did
what now no no no no
i didn't do you did literally
what did what well okay what happened
well you know every kid you know in
their day and age walks in on their
parents
um you didn't see me
um where you walked in on us once
once am i just finding about this now
live yeah neither of you actually know
about this
it never it never it never came out i
was just like i was just hit it
and i never killed a good conversation
um this might be a good conversation i
can't believe we're gonna do it now no
i'm not gonna but i can do my own
version of you know exactly what joke
i'm talking about i mean
let me ask you something what house was
this at we lived in a house for ten
years another house was matilda
of course it was and how old were you 18
my senior year high school oh
no oh yeah it was like yeah it was late
was it late at night no no it was uh
it was actually first thing in the
morning uh you left your car keys in
your room and i needed to drive to uh
travis school uh-huh so i had to knock
on the door actually
no i did knock on the door assuming you
guys were still asleep uh
we weren't nope damn it yep
i ended up being late to school because
i was like well
i'm gonna i'm gonna sit here for about
20 minutes and let them
you know do their thing and then about
20 minutes later i went back and knocked
on the door
and it was a long pause long pause long
pause
yeah and i was like i was like hey uh i
need your keys you're like they
they're you're like they're outside and
i'm like they're definitely not
they're in your pocket and i came over
and grabbed them out of your pants out
of your
jeans and i was like okay later i mean
yep yeah yeah so
i could do my version of of the joke of
when you walk into your parents
yeah i'm sure i i think i could do it
really well actually
but you don't have to
[Music]
you